hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that celebrates Legends
of film TV and maybe someday books you
laugh but only one of those things gets
you a free personal pan pizza on Tuesday
night as for our subjects today we're
talking two of the best in the game when
it comes to doing this thing with your
hands a couple of the finest film
framers who've taken on everything from
sending Sandra Bullock into space to
making Leonardo DiCaprio sleep inside a
horse like it's an expired Tauntaun on
the ice world of Hoth it's Alejandra
Gonzalez inaritsu and Alfonso Quran
right here right now on versus I'm your
host Mark Ellison if you're new to the
show
um we don't have either inaritsu or
Quran actually here they're probably off
making some great cinematic achievement
that's going to have a huge opening
weekend before it gets crowned the best
of the year at the Oscars now of course
if they wanted to show up we're not
going to lock the doors on them anyways
better than here in one corner it's
Alejandro who Once Upon a Time made a
whole movie about bird people that
looked like it was one shot and it takes
you like what eight jump cuts to make a
single Tick Tock in the other corner
it's Alfonso who went his talents to Big
Time franchises like Harry Potter and is
such a convincing filmmaker that we were
all cool with him sending George Clooney
to float to his death in outer space
it's a Victory lap for two filmmakers
from Mexico who've now conquered
Hollywood but since the show is called
versus we might as well have some
competitive fun during the process
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two Tomato
Meter slash audio score round three prom
theme round four power drills and then
we'll do a Wild Card round that somehow
will be more nutty than a roundabout the
most revered of high school dances or a
phase that focuses on Power Tools much
like the opening of a film directed by
Quran orionaritsu these rounds may not
make the most sense just yet enjoy the
ride it's all going to be explained in
due time you're in good hands albeit
these are tiny ones look I've been
putting these two together for these
filmmakers since a little princess and
21 grams respectively two movies that
sound very odd when paired together it's
time for a deep dive into the works of a
pair of directors who've been heralded
as masters of their craft so buckle up
get your space suits and avian wings
ready let's get it on I got a real treat
for you today round one box office
unlike most so-called Big Time directors
working today when we think Alejandro
Gonzalez scenarito or Alfonso Quran the
first thing that comes to mind may not
be how much money their films pull in
we're usually more focused on little
objects like art and storytelling and
craft but make no mistake kitties movies
are a business and in what may be
breaking news these Two Fellas helmed
some films that busted blocks and
stuffed vaults of cash into the bank
remember when I mentioned that Wizarding
World flick yeah those Harry Potter
movies tend to do okay but even before
Alfonso Quran took the Reigns for
Prisoner of Azkaban he had made a profit
with a 10 million dollar return on a
shoestring budget for 1995's a little
princess Great Expectations lived up to
its title raking in 55 million bucks and
itu mama tambien made 33 million dollars
in 2001 and the rave reviews from that
film helped Quran gain entrance to
Hogwarts where Azkaban would go on to
earn 789 million dollars which buys a
lot of butter beer I prefer mine Frozen
you told me he was Suave one kids are
drunk if the chosen one wizard kid thing
is quran's Ace in the Hole fret not
Alejandro Gonzalez inoritu fans he's got
Leonardo Dicaprio and Tom Hardy starring
and freezing in the Revenant and the
2015 Revelation grossed 532 million
bucks worldwide the year before Birdman
or the unexpected virtue of ignorance
made 102 million dollars which begs the
question if I have to say the whole
title from now on I feel like I said it
once it's out there from now on in this
show I'm just calling it Birdman I hate
you
and everyone you represent
I have stuff to do later those naps
don't take themselves selfish spoiled
children the year 2000 is when
enteritu's first film made the big
screen and Amores Perros took home 20
million dollars then 21 Grams hauled in
59 million bucks and then the Brad Pitt
starring Babel notched 132 million so we
got some Power Players here and Quran
simply can't rest on us Muggles to get a
victory in round one so what else you
got
I'm ready
oh right the final frontier not Star
Trek per se ooh can we get him to do a
Trek movie but that gravity flick it did
all right have 688 million dollars sound
to you that's not a Powerball jackpot
that's a movie and he pulled it off
he also did Children of Men which hippie
Michael caned its way to a Bill and Ted
approved 69 million dollars worldwide
total it's too close to call here
between these two directors with the
eyeball test so I reluctantly break out
my TI-82 calculator yeah so
I ain't crazy about your plan to date
Alfonso Quran has the higher total box
office digits with a career ranking of
1.6 billion dollars meanwhile inaritsu
is also impressed with an 873 million
dollar total the law of averages also
favors Quran here as his flick earns 236
million dollars per movie but inaritu
makes a strong case for himself with 146
million dollar average both filmmakers
have the box office to back up their
artistic Visions but it's Roma director
Alfonso Quran who gets to win in round
one and that's with his recent Oscar
winner having been released in theaters
for like what a day it got like one
showing you get in there you play the
movie now it's eligible for awards it
wins them all and we all leave happy
it's one to nothing in favor of Alfonso
are you drunk round two Tomato Meter
slash audience score and now the round
in which we knew we'd see some
impressive figures the box office draw
these two Titans wowed me but I'm
bracing ready for some high marks from
critics and audiences got a bunch of
Oscar contending films from these two
dudes more on that in the Pro round so
for right now let's head over to the
Tomato Meter and the audience score
Alejandro Gonzalez Santa Rita is looking
to get on the board and his loose
Trilogy that opened his career is a good
place to start amoris Perros is at 93
percent but from there we take a little
dip with 21 grams is 81 percent and
Babel 69 still fresh us all around but
inaritu wouldn't return to the 90s until
Birdman hit with a 91 percent the
Revenant followed up with a 78 percent
and I'll also give properties to
beautiful which is somehow his lowest
film on the resume resting at 66 percent
and now to quote Doc Brown
do you know what this means it means
that Alejandro Gonzalez and ritus never
made a rotten film let's keep that
energy going and see if Alfonso Quran
can match yeah try me well he's off to a
good start loving the time of Hysteria
was his first feature and despite not
being about the landmark Def Leppard
album the 1991 film is still fresh at 67
percent then a little princess set the
high standard for either director in
contention today with a 97 percent
quran's most recent two features at the
time of this recording sadly I'm not
live in studio feels like it though
right are also Super Fresh as Roma and
gravity get to hang out together in the
96 percent Club Children of Men and etu
mama tambien are 92 percent each the kid
of the Azkaban thing is 90 and Paris
jute aim was indeed loved by critics
earning an 88 percent so freshness is
here to stay except for Great
Expectations what
it's the only rotten flick we're talking
about at all today as it only earned a
37 in the veggie patch huh well the good
news is that it's 77 on the audience
score and that kids is what you call a
transition and guess what
I'll just tell you because I'm double
parked every single dang film is fresh
according to the audience and I believe
that's the first time we've ever had
that happen on the show do you have like
cake or balloons or popcorn I know where
the Russians stash their vodka this is
truly a first so let's party by seeing
what the highest film on this scale
could be well it's not as eye-popping as
a Tomato Meter but it's still worthy of
at least a cupcake amoris Perros the one
that started it all for inaritsu is his
best effort on the audience core metric
at 94 percent meanwhile quran's best is
a tie at 88 for etumabitambien and a
little princess Prisoner of Azkaban is
at 86 by the way well that's not good
enough not nearly good enough well it's
too dark some of your parents out there
what are you smirking at look them kids
are gonna have to learn about jail
eventually okay well might as well be
thanks to the Granger kid and that
Weasley ladder
all told the averages on each
measurement speak to the quality of
content that Alejandro Gonzalez inaritsu
and Alfonso Quran have been churning out
for a combined seven decades Alejandra's
Tomato Meter average is 79 and his
audience score is 80 percent Ken Alfonso
topped those gaudy integers barely yes
his TM is 84 and the as is 81 it's an oh
so close photo finish here in round two
but once again it's Quran who comes out
on top and suddenly he's a two to
nothing lead would be better
if you were to take that last breath
yours now the good news for inaritsu now
is that we get to kick off our Sunday
shoes and go dancing you know what has
to happen in a person's life for them to
become a Critic anyway
round three Prime theme
you master sluice out there have
probably deduced that I will not
actually be judging these beloved film
Craftsmen on their school dance resume
that's just a thought I can understand
if you don't want to remember prom for
most of us it was the first time that we
wore a tux and for some it was the most
recent time we wore at tux but not for
these two guys it seems like every year
they have a film and release they get
all dialed up and attend lavish
ceremonies with killer Swag Bags thus
this round we'll see who's currently
ahead in the awards game focusing
primarily on the most famous Golden Boy
who's not flown in over 6 million forms
of communication Oscar before we get
into Alejandro Gonzalez in aritsu and
Alfonso quran's individual achievements
can we toss some Applause towards
cinematographer Emmanuel uzbeki he's
worked with both Jens and as a result
has a ton of Hardware above his
fireplace he won in back-to-back years
as part of anaritu's crew for Birdman
and then the Revenant and he also took
home the best cinematography prize for a
Quran lead flick gravity which means yes
dude won three Oscars in three years so
between me and Emmanuel we have three
Oscars actually he was nominated for
Children of Men and A Little Princess
and when he's working with other
directors he got an odd for Sleepy
Hollow Tree of Life and New World which
was said in my old stomping grounds of
Williamsburg Virginia are you incapable
of restraining yourself or do you take
pride in being an insufferable
know-it-all
moving on all right now to the prizes
taken home by Alfonso and Alejandro as
far as the film's total amount of Oscar
wins goes quran's gravity is tops with
seven statues off of 10 nominations
including best picture and Best Director
the latter of which was won by him Roma
would also Garner 10 nods winning for
best foreign language film the first
movie from Mexico to ever earn that
honor
but it was inaritus the Revenant that
gathered the most nominations of any
movie were yapping about with 12 chances
at Gold it would ultimately cash in
three of them including a best actor win
for that kid from growing pains and the
year before Birdman won the top prize of
best picture that also won best original
screenplay and best director for
Alejandro as he became the first Mexican
filmmaker to take home three Oscars in a
ceremony they make their home country
proud and all of Earth is in awe with
the best stuff from innerito and Quran
but it's Alejandro who might pull away
in this round thanks to his
groundbreaking virtual reality work in
carne E Arena which won a special
achievement Oscar adding more coal to
the fire after a Morris Perros each one
of inaritu's films have gathered at
least one nomination for a performance
Babel saw nods for Best Supporting
Actresses for both Adriana Barraza and
renko Kikuchi Emma Stone and Michael
Keaton were each nominated for Birdman
as well and I really thought Keaton was
going to take home best actor but it was
Eddie Redmayne in The Theory of
Everything
all right but I mean could he play
Beetlejuice and Batman come on now why
do I always end up having to beg people
love me in another close contest this
time it's Alejandro Gonzalez inaritu
coming out on top and we got us a ball
game all of a sudden it's two to one and
it's still anyone's contest
well not anyone is probably going to be
one of these two directors winning in
all likelihoods so we'll move on round
four power drills
okay this round will not actually be
about who is better in the garage or
wood shop or anything else involving
very loud metal objects what's more
metal than Breaking new ground
especially when it comes to cinema hence
the power drill title both Santa Rito
and Karan have Blaze trails that the
rest of Hollywood is trying to keep up
in terms of Storytelling camera and
framing Styles and they do it all with a
signature flare that in each case has
taken a lifetime to develop listen to
the idiot he's really laying it on thick
isn't it well both directors may be on a
short list of modern game changers now
like a great film itself they each have
a unique opening act Alfonso Quran was
born in Mexico City in 1961 and as the
son of a doctor and biochemist he became
especially close with his Nanny a bond
that would come full circle decades
later with Roma by age 12 he was lucky a
movie camera around everywhere that got
him into film school but his rebellious
nature got him kicked out so he went to
work in the trenches on any TV and film
Project he could find around Mexico
doing odd job jobs that that day
required on set after impressing with a
movie at the Toronto International Film
Festival Sydney Pollock tapped him to
direct an episode of the Showtime
neo-noir series Fallen Angels Quran was
feeling out of his depth until he
received a pep talk from drum roll
please Alan Rickman the chat worked and
Quran ended up winning a cable Ace award
for directing the episode
Alejandro Gonzalez and aritu came into
the world a couple years after his
counterpart arriving in Mexico City in
1963. one of his earliest jobs was
traveling across the Atlantic to
exciting places like Europe and East
Africa and once he returned home it was
clear that he wanted to break into film
somehow some way after landing a plum
gig is a host on a popular rock station
in the 80s where they must have played
Def Leppard sometimes right he began
composing music for film screenwriting
would soon follow and in the year 2000
amoris Perez was released to much
Acclaim it's at this point in the
proceedings that I'll also tell our
audience that that translates to loves a
[ __ ]
which I would not agree with of course
all this is preamble to the giant leaps
they'd make as filmmakers in the years
that followed it was much more than a
small step for Cinema When Gravity was
released as Alfonso Quran showcased new
exciting techniques to make the audience
feel immersed in a zero gravity outer
space setting he made it look weightless
and effortless allowing us to focus on
the pulse-pounding suspense of the story
Prisoner of Azkaban is heralded as
possibly the best Harry Potter film and
this is in large part due to quran's
bold decisions to take the look at the
film in a darker Direction than the
previous two Chris Columbus entries
notably he added in more gray skies
looming in the distance a choice that
for him signified the impending clouds
of teenage and puberty approaching Roma
displayed a master class in patience
paying off many of the film's most
breathtaking moments are thanks to
longer shots that hold on a subject's
action proving that we don't always need
kinetic energy cuts to be drawn into a
story with the deaf Touch of Quran a
simple slice of life can culminate in an
emotional volcano Alejandro Gonzalez and
Rito knows a little something about long
shots Birdman plays out as one long take
even though it took much longer to put
together this would be a challenge for
any filmmaker if they were focused on
one setting but Birdman weaves all over
the city and includes such a stacked
cast of stars that the trick becomes all
the more impressive the experience of
tying in multiple story threads with
something like Babel must have proved
invaluable experience when it came to
Birdman but he was just getting warmed
up the Revenant wowed audiences with its
visceral tale of survival but the behind
the scenes is almost as incredible
inaritu shot with little to no help from
fancy lighting instead relying on
natural sources to shine on the action
and with the weather not always
cooperating to the point that an ideal
shooting location in Canada had to be
replaced with a snowy region in
Argentina it was always up to inarito
and his crew to make the day worth it
somehow some way and the stories of
DiCaprio doing everything from freezing
underneath the tent to eating a steady
diet of wild animal liver had become
that of Hollywood War all in the name of
making a truly memorable film
both directors will continue to blaze
new exciting Trails for future
generations to follow and for us the
audience to enjoy but the stunning
visuals and Untold sometimes unpopular
links that Alejandra Gonzalez inaritu
has gone in the name of entertainment
are certainly worthy of mention and a
point in this round he takes a w here
and suddenly we're all tied up at two
points a piece
moments of course it was going to come
down to this we love the making of
Mythology and the Oscar gold and
critical Acclaim and huge box office
receipts they keep the engine humming
but what really shifts the audience into
that next gear is a scene sequence or
surprise that keeps us yapping long
after the theater lights have gone back
up but let's start with the Revenant
because now that I brought up the
production scale I can't stop thinking
about it the Ari Cara attack is flat out
nuts shocking violence and sweeping
shots of arrows flying like GI Joe
cartoon lasers highlight a stunning
vicious Battle of territory and then
there's the bear attack look I know they
say to play dead because you can't
outrun a bear and they can climb trees
much better than you that being said go
watch that scene and tell me you'd be
able to just lay their emotionless while
a bear does a TSA pat down good luck
with that inarito's trilogy of films
that kicked off his career feature
scenes it would be harbingers of things
to come amoris Perros has a harrowing
crash then 21 Grams has an ending that
puts many of the ACT abilities on full
display within the same sequence the
kids will die moment in Babel veers
towards Terror whereas the birds in
beautiful are well the title of the film
says it all and speaking of birds give
the people what they want well we'll get
to Mr Keaton in just one sec for Alfonso
Quran he blessed us with inventive new
storytelling methods in Mr Potter's
sandbox can play with the menacing
Dementors and the Knight Bus scene plus
we see the kids get a little older wiser
and prepped to kick more ass I love when
Hermione gives Draco a good Pummel that
felt good the tenderness potency we see
in a little princess is fully realized
with settings like the ocean for Roma
breathtaking in scope and yet
wonderfully simple juxtapose peace and
Tranquility with the student protest in
that same Oscar winner and you see why
Quran is such a revered storyteller
E2 mama tambien has joyful dancing and
heartbreaking goodbyes gravity has an
all-time goodbye and amazing effects to
Marvel at but maybe the most striking
scenes in quran's entire catalog come
courtesy of Children of Men the worst
safe moment the creeping unease of
future events and sometimes even the
accidents help the blood spattering onto
the camera during one violent exchange
was not on purpose it was just a happy
mishap that ended up making perfect
sense given the Carnage that was
surrounding the lens in a round that I
would love to call a tied ball game I
have to lean slightly towards Alfonso
Quran here if for no other reason
because I find myself so emotionally
moved re-watching Roma a little princess
even Azkaban iteritu can grab my tear
ducts for sure and the jaw-dropping
efforts he and his crew went through to
pull off the Revenant and Birdman alone
are winworthy but something about Quran
and the breadth and depth of his work
are hitting me a little harder today
especially at around chock full of
memorable moments Alfonso cry Ron takes
a victory here and thus wins the match
this is very wise ah who are we kidding
they're both winners literally again go
back and watch the awards round they win
it all luckily the most recent efforts
have done boffo box office and garnered
heaps of Praise so maybe they can each
afford a second fireplace with more
mantle space upon which to place their
next crop of little golf fellas thanks
for tuning in to this episode of ursus
and remember this is all just my opinion
hit me up with your take at Mark Ellis
live on social media upcoming tour dates
at markellis.live and keep it right here
at Rotten Tomatoes and
rottentomatoes.com for all the latest in
the world of TV movies and inaritu and
Quran upcoming project thanks for
watching the show today we'll see you
next time and I am probably not gonna go
camping anytime soon